hey guys Jenny McCarthy here I'm on the
stage of Fox's new show the masked
singer and I'm gonna give you guys an
exclusive behind-the-scenes tour come on
[Music]
so this is the tunnel that the
celebrities walk out while they're
dressed in full costumes and their
identities are so kept secret that their
agents and their friends all have to
arrive wearing masks themselves so the
celebrities come out of this tunnel and
boom they are on the stage of the world
to see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're backstage in the Lear where they
keep all the characters and all the
costumes poodle is just is adorable I
mean you look like cotton candy I want
to eat you now see that could be a clue
so all of us judges up there have to
decipher what thing on her or what she's
singing could lead to an answer so we're
constantly shouting out guesses as who
can be I mean at one point I thought
Kathy Griffin with the fuzzy hair but
are you Kathy see
good luck poodle such a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is I the unicorn you can see that
these are not flimsy Halloween costumes
these are done with amazing creative
designers and celebrities and the
celebrities themselves choose who they
want to be this is a very unique
personality somebody actually designed
this and wanted to look like this now if
I as the panel judge would probably
guess this person is funny definitely
has a sense of humor maybe likes to ride
pineapple Express
could be from Hawaii likes to fake
working out I don't know maybe a
comedian next is the rabbit now this
isn't any ordinary rabbit look how
elaborate this is this is very scary I
mean this almost looks like a
straitjacket with these material things
hanging off I mean the outfits are not
cheap I mean this is leather
I mean gorgeous and stunning in person
again we have no idea who this is but I
would want to scream Jack Black or some
really kind of dramatic even magician
Criss Angel get it okay so you know this
costume probably has the biggest
celebrity because it is the most
beautiful ornate expensive costume in
the entire layout I think no offence
monster but look at it it is made with
gold it's super heavy
so some diva you know has to be a
professional singer in order to move
around the stage and be able to sing and
dance in this thing so I'm not guessing
any like you know want to be actors or
any kind of magicians or ridiculous
things like that so stay cool bro
so we're upstairs where the panel sits
and this is our little table and we have
obviously the best view in the whole
place look at the stage it is to me one
of those gorgeous stages I've ever seen
in a competition show - giant masks
where the singers the mass singers come
out and they battle each other and every
night
one person one celebrity gets tea masks
and boom the whole audience is always
surprised if that's of course for me
because I always guess right
[Music]